[Music]
joining me today is an accurate producer
a director and a good old-fashioned
liberal mark Duplass - welcome to the
Rubin report thanks for having me I'm
really looking forward to this because I
feel like destiny has put us here
house up old-fashioned liberal is
willing to have a conversation yeah
we're sort of a dying breed here I think
there were more of us than we think
probably but they're just they've kind
of been silenced or quiet or something
but before we get into all that stuff
let's just do a little bit of your
history and your work and stuff like
that because we're gonna go mostly into
politics great so uh in terms of your
work what what do you what do you want
people to know about you most then you
just said to me oh we don't have to do
much of that promote you know but for
the top someone tuning in that doesn't
know who we are
yeah I mean I think like uh I got my
start an independent film I was making
like little three dollar movies with my
brother and and start out at the
Sundance Film Festival and I really was
just like a kid from the suburbs who
didn't know what he was doing and and we
ended up kind of building this career
kind of brick by brick you know our
first feature was a $15,000 movie and
and then I kind of made my way into into
Hollywood eventually and I kind of have
one foot in the Hollywood system where I
work as a writer and an actor and I and
I have one foot outside right where I
continue to produce and make my own
movies and you know I've been in shows
like the league where a lot of people
would know me from and uh ran a show for
HBO called togetherness for a while and
and you know basically I'm sort of like
trying to try to find a way to be
exactly who I want to be creatively
inside of the Hollywood system without
drowning inside of it yeah and I mean my
audience knows that I find that concept
fascinating because I've sort of bounced
around from some kind of mainstream
stuff to online stuff to now owning what
I do and even for you that's a little
more entrenched in the Hollywood system
that you're trying to figure out your
way it's pretty cool and I've read some
articles where you talk about that just
how do how do I build what I want and
own it and feel good about it that's the
challenge it is a real challenge and you
know the industry continues to change
and you know it's a lot like our world
right now you know like for whatever
reason you know I'm headed towards this
place of ownership where I feel like the
only way for me to do exactly what I
want to do creatively maintaining not
only creative control but but honestly
control the environments in which I work
work with really nice people work with
be able to support young people my
brother and I are big on like mentoring
young talent as producers and raising
them up at studios just don't want that
they want to prove in talent you know
and so them I always thought my career
was going to be start at Film Festival's
start independently and that will be a
stepping stone to get to Hollywood and
when they get to Hollywood I'm going to
be sick right and then I got here in my
late 20s and I was like I'm set I'm here
but I don't like this yeah this is
really weird
and strangely enough choosing
independence and choosing ownership has
not only been better for me creatively
but it's actually been a lot better
financially and in the long run you know
so we're now in this weird spot where
we're kind of like running our own
production on all of our own TV shows
and movies we kind of work in television
my brother works in transparent I work
in you know like the league and things
like that and I make money there and I
fund my own stuff and and we're like our
own little studio yeah which is which is
funny to me because you know I always
joke how I really am as liberal as they
come when you look at me on paper except
when you look at what I've done from a
business perspective I am at the very
least a physical conservative yeah but
probably probably more libertarian than
anybody else where I'm just like you
know if you look at Hollywood as
government right right get away I don't
want you in my face let me do my thing
I know what I'm doing I'll handle it
myself you know that that is a very
conflicting thing with a lot of my
liberal philosophies yeah even that
interesting though because that's sort
of where the rubber meets the road like
you have this idea now you've built
something you know wait a minute I'll
either want to keep what I've earned or
I want to spend it the way I feel is
right or any of that stuff and that's
where your ideas actually get out
it's 100% I look at a you know a hollow
production I see waste everywhere you
know I'm just like you are spending on
catering one day's time during for a
Marvel movie what I spend on a whole
movie yeah you know literally you're not
making a ton about money that's better
and that and that drives me insane and I
understand how conservatives look at
government a lot of something they're
like this makes me insane the
inefficiency makes me insane so I'd
rather just get rid of the whole thing
yeah and so I get that I know we don't
have a whole craft services thing for
you in the gaming room but I bet
otherwise we're okay fiji water but
water that off he was at least a six out
of ten so I'm back Miss Priss oh man
yeah that's pretty good
that's good that's the good stuff like
it's that bigger stuff all right well we
could I'm going to ask you a little more
about Hollywood at the end or if it kind
of relates to all the politics but
politics is kind of how we got here I
saw you on steven crowder and he's a
buddy of mine and we have all our
political differences and we put those
aside for to come and talk and that's
exactly what you did on his show and
immediately after on Twitter everyone's
like Dave you got to get this guy he did
there's another one of you there's a
religion or the first one that everybody
says yeah I want to crowd and they're
all like you gotta go see Ruben all
right so so here we are so first let's
just talk about growing up because you
mentioned this on Crowder and we spoke
that earlier you grew up in a Regan
household in the south hundred percent
tell me I drove in New Orleans grew up
in the suburbs you know my grandfather
was you know ninth grade education built
his laundry cleaners business by himself
pretty much sure he stole somebody to do
it like we were we were that guy he
either said that we were that self-made
family my dad was the first guy to go to
college went you know became a lawyer
and we we were this family that was like
in-group out-group mentality like it
talked about like the America first
attitude we were just do plus or like we
are in our home we're finally
financially sustainable here we've moved
into the middle class you know and and
and Reagan was God in our house you know
is you know like here we go
like let's cut these taxes let's take
care of it trickle-down economics is
going to work for us you know and and I
guess you know you could call that that
fiscal conservatism but but realizing
the value of a dollar realizing that
like if I can just get my arms around my
own
and run at my own way we can do it and
my father worked at a big law firm he
split off when he was 30 when we were
very young took the chance started his
own firm with his own money invested in
it and built his thing and I have always
looked to that model and thought that
feels very very right to me you know in
my core you know I know that's you know
like I said it's very it sounds like
exactly what you're doing with yourself
right now it is what I have done in the
film business and I really followed
those those footsteps and I didn't think
about it until I started to think a
little bit more politically and I
started to actively look for connection
points you know between liberals and
conservatives libertarians I started
asking myself those questions and I said
what do you share you know what makes
you not the classic elitist Hollywood
living heart that everyone thinks you
are you know right right we'll talk
about those beers one you know here's
one here's one thing yeah and and and
it's been interesting to me because you
know the more I talk about that with
conservatives they're like yeah that's
that's me I look at the government the
way you're looking at Hollywood same
thing yeah so a lot of this you're sort
of awakening to this or this this sort
of last couple months where you've kind
of been reaching out to the other side
and trying to figure out what people
think and all that it has a lot to do
with Election Day right yeah Election
Day was big for me
you know I've I've been not very
politically involved my whole life I've
been very self oriented self involved in
terms of like how do I become a
successful artists because as you know
your stand up for all it's so hard it
requires all your time and energy
I was very insular focused having
children got me a little more out of
myself and then the election pulled way
out of myself you know in my first
reaction like you know all of my friends
and a lot of liberals out there was just
blind anger and fear and I was very
upset I was fulfilling we were going to
take a lot of steps backwards and I just
started screaming on Twitter you know
and making I was doing it in funny ways
with comi I was doing incendiary ways I
was you know it ought admittedly
grabbing headlines of things when I
wasn't even fully of that educated about
them getting them out it just being like
this is terrible
yeah and you know while I think that
some of those opinions
were and still are valid when I honestly
looked at like what the outcome was I
was like well that's just chumming me up
more closely to people who already
believe like I do and creating a further
device from people who don't believe
like I do so I was aware enough and I've
been to therapy enough to know after a
few weeks like this is Hylian not
productive so how can I find a way to
channel some of this and and do it for
good you know and look I'm a I don't
really hide this like I'm a person who
has been through a lot of anxiety in my
life a lot of depression in my life I've
been through therapy for a long time I
learned how to communicate and deal with
very complicated relationships I work
with my wife I work with my brother who
was also my best friend my parents lived
two miles from me we hang out every
Sunday with the whole family and I know
I guess what it means to be the first
one to say you're sorry even if you
think the other person may have done
even worse to you how to move that bin
first I know what it means to stop
looking at what all the differences are
to ferret out connection points and to
try to nurture those things and grow
them so that you can start to
effectively communicate that's what I
made my whole life about I'm lucky
enough to be an upper-middle-class
person who didn't have to deal with
starvation so I dealt with relationships
and so when I started thinking about
that I was like maybe there's a space
for me to try to reach out with some of
these things that I've learned in the
political arena then I changed my
Twitter tactic really - from yelling -
sorry sorry about the yelling is there
something you want to tell me that I
don't understand and then the first
question I asked which was you know if
you held your nose and voted for Trump I
get it I was on fire for Hillary and a
little bit of nose holding for me too
you know I'm psyched about having the
first female president she was going to
guard my basic policies I wanted to get
the Supreme Court of 90 that I thought I
could get for her
yeah it was good it was working for me
you know if you looked at Trump in that
way you're you're a one-issue voter
you're pro-life or you wanted that
Supreme Court justice that he would get
for you you know great if you're on fire
for Trump I don't understand it
so please try to explain this to me and
it was very interesting by pulling back
and not yelling and just by being
willing to listen I got a bunch of
really good responses from people saying
like first of all thank you for just
listening just that right that was young
fish you know and I was like oh I have
been here really bummed about these
really loud and Sandy Airy quite frankly
[ __ ] conservatives who have been
tweeting at me saying these horrible
things to me and I'm like a bunch of
people on the left doing that to them -
mm-hmm and I realize how much they
appreciated me not doing that and I was
like oh they're feeling it too so we're
at least equally guilty on this side of
slinging [ __ ] at each other yeah so
let's pause there for a sec yeah because
I think what's interesting is as a guy
that lives and works in Hollywood that
for me and I mentioned you before I've
only lived in New York in LA oh you know
I've never lived in the middle of
country but I think I've been sort of
attuned to what they're talking about
because I had a few guest on like Scott
Adams who created Dilbert and even Milo
who it's a different thing but was
talking about what the people are
attracted to in Trump and a couple other
people that I heard it so when the
election happened I can't say that I was
totally shocked yeah I was on Joe Rogan
show the day before and I said I think
it could happen like I really wasn't
shocked were you completely shocked how
much was the shock related to the
lashing out hundred percent I would say
that they were part and parcel and
because like the policies bother me and
some of the policies still very much
bother me and and and that's you know
almost beside the point of what I'm
trying to do in this space but but I was
certain yeah that Hillary would win and
part of that is because I was just not
that politically educated and I was
really resting on my laurels you know I
had great eight great basic years with
Obama as far as I was concerned and I
was reading headlines but I wasn't
reading all the articles you know I was
like we're good it's rest and so this
was a big awakening for me
yeah and I think that you know 8 to 10
years from now I think they're going to
be a lot of people are going to say one
of the best things I have in this
country was getting Trump elected so
that people could wake up and they could
start reading deeper into the headlines
and start to figure out where we belong
and you know I know that I is when I say
something like that and this is a
sensitive subject and I don't know how
to say it correctly but I know that as
an upper middle class white male I have
a certain comfort to be able to say like
it's time to heal the divide because
there are a lot of people who would just
be like easy for you to say man you're
not in the direct crosshairs of the
policy that this man is trying to enact
that could threaten you you know so I'm
like I get that but I can only speak
from where I am and what I believe in
and somewhere deep in my gut I was
raised Catholic like I was raised on New
Testament stuff I was raised on Jesus
principles I rejected them all got away
from religion but like the core yeah of
being a person for others and and the
MLK message and the Jesus message of
like the only way forward is through
creating positivity reaching out trying
to find laughter and building something
out of that it's what I've learned in my
marriage like my wife and I going to go
for 15 years it's basically the best
marriage I could have hoped for but we
have our shitty moments yeah and when
when I look at our marriage and I look
at that is a microcosm for the country
and the gridlock that's happening when
things are really bad for us we promised
ourselves we're not going to point out
our differences anymore we're going to
look for connection points and a lot of
times that is a lowest common
denominator connection point for us it's
the big lebowski sex pack of course like
yeah when we go that we can sit on couch
together yeah and not look each other
and enjoy this thing again the good
vibes start to come and then suddenly
like one of us will be like you want to
order some Chinese food I'll get it and
then the person Oh was a generous nice
little store through there yeah and then
Chinese so he comes in like yeah I'll
put on the plates for us and I'll bring
it out and then all side brick by brick
by not examining the differences but the
things we could share
you get there you know and I again I'm
jumping into something that I'm not
fully aware of the consequences I am NOT
as well read as I should be on politics
to even be on this show but my goal is
to try and find these connection points
with people who disagree with me as much
as possible honestly yeah we can build
[Music]
you